first of all couple things
sad day for comedy sad weekend for
comedy
oh yeah um i just want to say a couple
things about my dear friend kate uh
quigley who i love very much i know you
love her she's our friend dude she's
always been great genuine friend of mine
i text her a few days ago a real comic
uh uh and you know what just as
misfunctional and a misfit like the rest
of us and part of it's what makes me
love her so much i think that she like
all of us have her
things and her issues and i think this
is a wake-up call for her and i'm sure
she'll talk about it but um
i it's it's look man like you were
talking you know we have friends that do
their share of blow it's part of the
community it's part of
show business it's part unfortunately
and like you said you don't know if this
shit's been cut without rolling the dice
you are rolling the dice every time and
fentanyl is unforgiving i have a buddy
who's hardcore not hardcore but he knows
the the drug game and he's like yeah man
the chinese and the cartel they're lazy
because they can prolong and get more
out of the product they don't care about
you though what do you mean oh really
they don't care about they don't have
quality yeah so they're they're putting
fentanyl in because
it can make it last longer yeah like it
doubles so they don't have to put as
much pure cocaine in it yeah so make
sure you make sure you get if you do
cocaine it's locally sourced and you
know the farmers go to colombia you
can't do it yeah just stop doing it just
stop you rolling every time you're
rolling the dice you're rolling the diet
figure out what you got
thank god kate's okay thank [ __ ] well
she's out of the icu but she's not okay
yet you know she's she's it's going to
be a long road here she's got yeah this
is well
just like a texas if she needs anything
hit us up i said that too and and you
know foo i didn't
yeah i knew him around the way he was he
was just a good guy everyone loved him
he was he was probably one of the most
like
warming uh
people in the scene like he like he
just accepted people with open arms and
it was just a funny
funny funny guy yeah you know
i met him when we were on a show
together
he was he was yeah he was so funny and
just a good guy
seriously
that's what i'm saying like his energy
was just yeah david knew him really well
yeah david newman
then this other comic who i didn't know
either but uh apparently a great guy
yeah and and uh you know the whole thing
sucks and that woman i didn't know her i
guess
williamson uh natalie williams no doing
blow though man it's literally a [ __ ]
crap shoot man yeah it's insane it's
just it it really sucks but kate's a
dear friend man thank you god it's okay
and then my favorite one of my favorite
actors and you were with me uh michael k
williams who died of a heroin overdose
and i guess he had always struggled with
heroin my buddy frank grillo did two
movies with him and was just love that
dude and i i remember you were with me
such a talent and you were with me a
talent at the premiere of ride-along yep
i saw him and i don't do the standing on
the elevator yep i don't do this to any
actor and i walked up to him and i said
i love you i think we were on the
elevator with him yep and i said to my
god i love you so much i think you're
one of my favorite actors yeah i i i
said so too didn't know how to tell he
makes it look so like oh
he in the world
come on he's the moral compass of the
show yes
yes
he's great
everything he does he's great i loved
him he had a hard life he came up hard
but he was beautiful man
that's such a shame it's how many people
have how many more people do we have to
lose to this [ __ ] until people start
stop doing it
you get caught up in that heroin [ __ ]
it's so hard to stop any any of that
[ __ ] it's all just like a tough world
being an addict is very hard
we all we all know people who've had it
we have family members that are you know
we've all unfortunately have we deal
with it it's an american
problem yeah and it's it's part of the
american
story yeah yeah unfortunately it's hard
it's a hard fight for people yeah man
freaking shame anyway
so that's that's you brought that up
yeah i had to just give a little shout
out to kate yeah
i mean i think you've seen each other in
a while so i haven't you know i forget
all the [ __ ] we got to catch up on
that's terrible yeah i know it's been a
while yeah